transport ministers meeting today in
Luxembourg discussed how to improve rail
services in the EU through a possible
market opening for domestic passenger
services and stronger governance
according to the Italian presidency it
was a broad and very discussion on the
technical and political pillars of the
fourth whale whale package we discussed
the technical pender the political
pillar the reciprocity clause opening of
domestic passenger markets and the radio
super re lechesa you need to guarantee
equal access to procurement tenders to
the rolling stock we also talked about
cherry-picking namely that we should
guarantee that people don't just
participate in the markets that are
profitable but they should be present
everywhere the council adopted also a
general approach on new rules for access
to the port services market in the EU
and to ensure the financial transparency
of ports the objective of the new rules
is to promote fair competition and
reduce legal uncertainties they also
reached the general approach on a draft
directive to facilitate the cross-border
exchange of information on road traffic
offenses such as speeding not using a
seat belt talking on the phone or
driving under the influence of alcohol
and drugs finally and for the first time
ministers had a look at the
possibilities for the civil use of
drones
you